you worked with Jessica a lot have you
told her any Scottish phrases or I don't
think tour too much but I remember
sitting here on this couch everywhere
they go with them I was about to say
Dame metal strip she's not a damn no
should be you're right American yeah
cold metal sweep and there and I tried a
Scottish phrasing or to see if she could
understand what I was saying so try it
on oh yeah all right
this place is pure watching me bow bangs
this place is pure approaching Mabel
banks this place watching me ball banks
yeah but what does it mean this place is
making your balls feel protected Canada
I'm gonna bank
this place is full of Egypt's or idiots
Robert who was very keen on your English
accent oh yeah I'm clean and American in
this film with Robert Redford and I'd
I'd played an American but I don't stay
in the American accent in between takes
and stuff but find that quite annoying
for some reason so I go to mom like here
here's the thing in blah blah blah what
are you thinking I should do this I
think you should do that me but like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa do the American
accent I was like I can't express myself
properly if I'm like common if I'm actin
in between takes he says well can you do
an English accent in between teeth can I
do it yes because he could understand
that and he couldn't understand mine
what
[Music]
you